Max Josh cinnamon congratulations your
hard teamwork has paid off and vaulted
you into this final round of competition
but this round the gloves are off
now we're gonna find out which one of
you has what it takes to become the
fortune fire Champion going five
straight hours in a choose your own
Damascus competition head to head
against your friend I'm Josh Hardman and
I'm 18 years old from Colorado Springs
Colorado I'm Max harder I'm 18 years old
and I'm from Colorado Springs Colorado
copycat
phone calls
we know each other from working together
Josh and I are both full-time
blacksmiths bladesmiths and welders Max
and I are real close friends we see each
other all day pretty much every day you
ready man ready all right now gentlemen
we have chosen what blade we want you to
build you're going to be building this
the kinjal sword
tracing its roots back to the 3rd
Century BC the kinjal sword remains
popular in Georgia to this day
featuring a double-edged blade and
distinctive Hilt this weapon was ideal
for stabbing and slashing enemies in
close quarter combat
the kinjal was such a Lethal Weapon the
Russian army continued to carry this
Fierce blade in battle well into the
20th century
we have five hours on the clock so good
luck stay sharp your time starts
now I'm getting my steel all ready to
weld up I'm making Damascus stack out of
abcrv2 15 and 20 and 1095. I'm gonna let
my steel heat up and then Flex it and
then put it back in and get it up to
Affordable temperatures I I did it
everything's looking solid right now so
I just try to work it down as fast as
possible well that can happen in a
quench especially for a blade this long
could have tendency to Warp
boom in the old areas everything looks
pretty good there isn't a ton of time in
this round so I got to use my time
wisely so while I let my blade cool down
from quench I'm going to quickly take a
little bit of material off my handle
scales that way it makes grinding it
easier later
so next thing I'm doing is start working
on my handle
I just had to make a mosaic pin it'll be
pretty quick and just take a couple
extra minutes little details especially
when going up against Max it's going to
be really important my Globe goes Super
smoothly get it all clamped together so
that way I can work on the blade still
first thing I'm going to do is get my
ability of Damascus stacked up going for
about 20 layers or so everything's
looking real solid it all feels like
it's moving one solid piece so I'm going
to move on to drawing it out this is
only 18 inches long
best way for me to do one of these
integral Garden pommels is just to put
the material where I need it and then
grind it the rest of the way I'm looking
for a tool that I can kind of fit into
the shoulders and push down material so
I just take some mild round bar and weld
it together in the configuration I need
all right Max is in the oil it's
perfectly straight gotten a good hard
blade I want to make sure that I've got
a good oval shaped handle I've got my
handle kind of rough shaped I'm just
going to leave it at that for now and
I'm going to do a bit more finish grind
on the blade it's really important that
I acid etch this blade if I don't the
judges aren't going to be able to see
the pattern and that's the whole point
of doing this process
after the acid Edge I'm just going to do
some final shaping on the handle and
then put an edge on my blade
everything's looking good turned out
real nice we've done a head schedule I
don't have anything to do first match
okay
what is this we've got nothing left to
do so we're gonna eat some fruit snacks
five four three two
two one put down your candy this round
is over
late Smiths welcome to the dynamic kill
test
if I know how lethal your weapons are
how sharp they are and how wieldable
they are in my hands I will take your
king jail swords and deliver some lethal
blows and ballistics dummy and try to
cut through these watermelons Max you're
up first you ready for this yep
thank you
[Music]
all right Max talking about your kinjal
sword here first up nice job of bringing
out the pattern
now your handle construction is smooth
your Edge is sharp and took no damage
it's got a nice balance to it it's
pointy it's sharp and
you'll kill right here
Josh your turn you ready yes sir
foreign
[Music]
Josh let's talk about your king gel
sword here it's nice to see that profile
that has a slight curve at the kinjal
swords have but when you look up close
you can see that there are uneven grinds
on your blade but your Edge is sharp and
it took no damage on this test it's got
a nice balance and more importantly your
king gel sword will kill
thank you
all right placemats welcome to the
dynamic strength test
[Music]
match your first journey for this ready
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
Max it is comfortable it fits my hand
really well it's nice and rounded
there's no hot spots or any problems
there cutting into the banner you have a
cane Edge but it's not a wicked sharp
edge I can run my finger along here
without any worry of getting cut and
then you can see it a little bit in the
banner there's some more tearing than
clean slicing but in general this is a
strong blade held upgrade in the ice and
it cut the banners nice job thank you
hi Josh you're up you ready yes sir
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign Josh the grinds you have on here
are a little bit rough the rough grinds
make it a little difficult to see your
patterns so starkly and uh the shape of
It kind of meanders a little bit as you
move along but it is sharp there are
some spots on here that took some
dulling and you can see on that
horizontal strike it really just stopped
but all in all I think you did a good
job thank you
[Music]
all right gentlemen when the beginning
of this competition you guys showed us
you're both very talented Smiths
especially when working together as a
pair but at the end of the day only one
of you can leave here as a fortune fire
champion and get that check for ten
thousand dollars
today's Fortune fire Champion is
Max congratulations
now Josh you fought hard you're a
talented Smith but unfortunately your
blade did not make the cut I'm gonna
have to ask you to please step off the
forge floor
I'm really happy for Max the competition
hasn't come between us as friends he'll
always be my best bud I completely agree
with the judge's choice if I were to do
it again I'd probably try to even out my
grind a little bit more
good job Max you did good so see you at
home
Max congratulations that makes you a
fortune fire Champion you'll be
receiving a check for ten thousand
dollars congratulations thank you this
is really exciting had an awesome week
competing with Josh I'm walking away
with the Titleist Fortune fire Champion
but it took my work with Josh to get me
here
so once you're playing with the money
I'm getting married in June so I'll
probably save the money for that Wise
Wise man if it had been a competition
against strangers I would have been here
to win but competing with Josh
definitely turned it into just a good
time to hang out with one of my best
friends